stay optimistic if you want to achieve
success as an entrepreneur you have to
stay optimistic that it's going to work
out because life is gonna throw you
curveballs you're gonna make a lot of
mistakes you might lose a lot of money
you're gonna have the little man in your
life tell you all the reasons why your
ideas not gonna work out
you need to stay optimistic that it will
one of my favorite stories is of Walt
Disney when he was a little boy his
father beat him regularly that was his
form of I don't know getting rid of some
aggression but he took it out on his son
Walt and I had a really young age Walt
started drawing and doodling and in his
life at home sucked and instead of
getting down on himself he remained
optimistic and created this fantasy land
for himself where he imagined he was
playing and living when he got a little
bit older the war was on and so he
joined the army he went and he was an
ambulance driver in France and all he
saw around him was people with their
limbs being blown off and blood
everywhere and just misery and he was in
the ambulance driver right imagine how
much bad stuff you see every day and he
remained optimistic and he wanted people
to be happy
and so how do you how do you be happy
you've been picked up in your name Buell
ins and a little touch of he added was
he would draw cartoons and sketches all
over his ambulance of happy creatures
and people having a good time to try to
uplift people's spirits he remained
optimistic even in the hardest
circumstances he came back to America he
wanted to start his own business he
wanted to be an animator he wanted to
create his own creations and share it
with the world and it got so hard for
him that he was in Kansas City and he
couldn't afford to have an apartment
anymore so he slept at his office he
lived at his office he ate cold beans
every day because he couldn't afford
real food but he remained optimistic
that it was going to work out and then
finally finally after all this crap that
happened to him after all of these
failures and and not see any momentum or
success he finally has something that
takes off and it was Mortimer the Lucky
Rabbit
that was his first creation that really
had some commercial success and we made
the pivotal mistake of agreeing to allow
the copyrights for Mortimer the Lucky
Rabbit to go to his distributor and then
a distributor cut him out of the deal
and he lost his first creation and
instead of getting down on himself he
arraigned optimistic he thought it was
gonna work out and he thought back to
the times when he was in Kansas City in
his office sitting on his cold floor and
there was a pack of mice that were
always hanging around in his office and
one of them became a really close friend
of Disney and he treated him as a pet
and so Walt Disney said you know what my
next creation I'm gonna make it a mouse
and it became Mickey Mouse he remained
optimistic he remained positive that it
would work out and eventually it did
even though he got pounded and beat down
and got screwed over and saw such
terrible things in his life he remained
optimistic that it would work out one of
my favorite quotes the Disney said just
shortly before he died was I hate to see
downbeat pictures I know life isn't that
way and I don't want anyone telling me
it is so stay optimistic and believe
that it's gonna work out you guys like
this video give it a thumbs up below you
can click on the link in the description
to support me leave a comment let me
know what you think and click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon